before I get styling this I want to
really thank a lot of people and what
every single person but I got an immense
number of responses into the Edmodo
group what people took their pictures of
like what they knew about surface area
and volume and one of the things that
people drew if you did have drawings
what presumes president we all need to
start off with this so we know what
we're talking about we've looked at
prisms since you seven would anyone like
to extend what's like a nice succinct
definition for a prism any takers
give us some words the reaction Isis is
a prism of flat shape it's not it's it's
got how many dimensions three dimensions
so let's write that it's a three
dimensional shape okay now we know lots
of three-dimensional shapes a sphere is
a three-dimensional shape is a sphere a
prism that's using it actually has a lot
of things that are quite close to being
prison but it's not can someone tell me
what is what might be a prison yeah
right thank you
Oh cute Oh cute let's all draw a little
cube up here a cube is a prison so what
is it about a cube that makes it prison
and not a sphere what's what quality
does it have say again spear is round
hmm we don't like roundness when we talk
about prisms is there anything else cuz
that's true anything else we can
identify yeah what are you gonna get
okay we could talk about faces how many
faces is a cute hat does a prism have to
have six faces no I can have a whole
bunch of numbers of different faces so
number of face is important but maybe we
don't need it in the definition ya know
and you also had your hand up again do
you want office um yeah okay sure that's
fine it is an obvious fact about this
let me give you a bit of a clue again
words the word prism comes from a word
in in our language that means slice or
saw like literally cut across
right does that give us any clues about
this I can say that phrase again
cross-section okay you all drew that
cube right in that cube let's draw a
cross-section
that's fine um let's draw a cross
section of this cute man you can draw a
lots and lots of different ones just for
the sake of consistency let's all draw
the same one something like this okay
that's right there in the middle as if I
cut the thing in half okay so that
cross-section the special thing about a
Q is that we just drew one of the cross
sections but any of the other cross
sections that I drew they would be the
same thank you very much okay so now we
have a definition three national shape
weird the way I'm going to choose is a
consistent process
[Music]
okay let me add one more thing in
brackets to this which is that we
usually state for prism the same thing
with two of our faces before in straight
edges we usually want that cross section
to be a polygon later on in this topic
I'm going to explain why I put this in
black and I don't think it's as
important as the rest of the definition
okay so we know what a prism is this
kind of shape what surface area this
will be a bit quicker it's a very simple
concept how would you define surface
area yeah right nice okay just take the
words rearrange okay so area is not a
three-dimensional thing right it's not a
three-dimensional thing it's a
two-dimensional thing all right so it's
the two-dimensional space
that's what area is after all that now
we're going to go all the way around I
guess and that's colloquial way to say
it is you've got to cover that shape
cover the prism
okay now in order to work this out I
wonder I mean Christmas was not that
long ago how many of you actually wrap
Christmas presents rather like handing
out to someone yeah okay let's have you
fantastic
I am I spent a lot of time wrapping
Christmas presents once you have your
object you want to wrap it around okay
if you did it exactly like no overlap or
anything like that for something like
this if I took all of the
two-dimensional space that covers that
shape what would it look like
hmm you actually have a really fancy
mathematical neck starts with an end if
you took this and you unfold it you
would get a net very good
now this is not in the title but it's
just as important and that is the result
of unfolding the faces of a ship now
even though this wasn't in the title can
you see why it's important you want to
find the surface area of a prism that's
the same as finding the area of the net
most nets for cubes look like this you
might want to draw this up next to where
your cube is okay most nets for a cube
look like that you can almost imagine
falling that up in your head but they
don't have to be like that there's lots
of difference you could draw like this
that will work just fine you could do
other shapes that are different as well
okay the more people have the same area
they're all talking about the same shape